hey guys Maxwell here for another
gamespot news update where as it turns
out Respawn Entertainment System seller
titanfall wasn't originally planned for
the Xbox one Richard Baker lead engineer
respawn entertainment said that it was a
PC game from the start quote originally
we weren't planning on an xbox one
version of the game I'm certain that
having an Xbox one version has made our
pc version much better it justified the
effort in moving to dx11 and even 64 bit
titanfall is currently a core component
of Microsoft's Xbox one strategy
marketing executive Yusuf Mehdi said
earlier this week there are
advertisements for the game all over TV
and online and Microsoft even created a
special limited run titanfall bundle
which includes a free copy of the game
with the purchase of an Xbox one to mark
the game's release however developer
respawn has stated previously that they
are open to bringing the game to other
consoles if they ever move on to
titanfall 2 and of course for everything
that is titanfall be sure to subscribe
to gamespot on YouTube and head on over
to gamespot com I'm fine um fun back
there